Spotify has been out for more than ten
years while Apple music is now premiere
for years but despite this up Emilia has
come out on top in the US market having
more paid subscribers Spotify still has
the worldwide advantage a number of
users but it's just a matter of time
before Apple eats them up make sure to
stick around till the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Horry sorry so I'm going to
be going over the main differences
between Spotify and Apple music starting
off with music discovery Spotify has
discovered weekly which comes out every
Monday and recommends 30 new songs these
songs are picked by our algorithm and
are based on the music that you have
listened to in the past
Spotify also has a discover page where
it gives you recommendations of songs
based on the artists that you'd
frequently listen to ask for a pop music
when you start off they ask you selected
genres and artists that you're
interested in and based on these
selections Apple music will give you
recommendations on playlists and artists
based on what it thinks that you will
like both services allow you to like a
song which will help in the
recommendation process but as for music
discovery Spotify definitely has the
edge as for subscription fees both
services will cost you $10 a month
Apple was trying to offer eight or even
in $5 a month but clearly this does not
set well with the vast majority of their
label right owners they also offer
family packs which covers up to six
devices for a total monthly fee $15 a
month until June of 2019 Spotify also
offered a free ad based hula
subscription which is worth about $6 but
this was exclusive to premium
subscribers excluding family plans also
for both services if he scoured the
internet well enough you can probably
find them for $99 per year so they both
have pretty much the same pricing but
where Spotify sticks out is that most of
their users are actually free users
these people do have to deal with ads
but this is a population that Apple
really can't touch with their best offer
that even comes close that it's three
months of free trial
this gives Spotify access to a
demographic and revenue stream the Apple
does not even have access to so as for
subscription fees Spotify has the
advantage as for user interface their
browser tabs are pretty similar they
both display new music playlists
concerts and videos on both services you
can also save songs that you have access
to in your library you know how to
search for it again but with Apple music
the artist pages are clean and easy to
navigate each album is clearly
separately displayed with their
respective album art but with Spotify it
just dumps all the songs you've saved
into a huge list we have no distinction
as to where albums start and end it is a
lot cleaner if you go to the online
artist page but this completely defeats
the purpose of downloading songs for
offline news also if you're looking at
Apple devices clearly Apple software is
going to run better and be more fluid on
Apple devices but even aside from Apple
devices Apple music does have the UI
advantage and next we have social
features which is a very important part
of listening to music
Spotify subscribers can follow friends
and see what they listen to and what
artists they like you can share and
recommend playlists and you can even
publish your music listening history on
Facebook as for Apple music they have a
connect function which connects artists
and fans together artists are able to
share exclusive information insight with
their fans walk connect to school Apple
music lacks a friend to friend component
that many people really like as a result
Spotify also has better integration of
social features as her radio it's really
a shame that Spotify removed radio and
instead they added assisted playlists
these are recommendations are based on
your interests and Premium users get
access to what Spotify calls endless
artists radio this is available for
select artists and our personalized
playlists based on their listening
history but unfortunately Spotify no
longer has regular radio stations
available as for Apple they have their
own radio station called beats one where
they play non-stop music every single
day they also have bebés
News ESPN and several of generic radio
stations this one goes to Apple now
there are some things are unique to
Spotify and such as work out modes this
used to be a built-in feature but now
you have to download barkeeper our Nike
Plus in order to use it
Spotify will actually select playlists
that match your line temple there are
small touches like this that Apple
simply does not have Apple music has
workout theme music
but it is a extra little flair that it
is lacking and just like this there are
several small features that Spotify has
that Apple that's not so Spotify takes
the win here ask for music library
Spotify has over 20,000 songs every
single day and they have a catalog of
over 35 million songs Apple music on the
other hand has 45 million songs in their
catalogue and had several exclusivity
deals but you can find the vast majority
of music on either service but Apple
does have a slight issue as for offline
downloads with Apple looking at their
music on up to 10 device at the same
time and up to 100,000 songs now so many
songs that you'll probably run out of
storage before you get limit ask for
Spotify you can only download our songs
on up to five devices at once and hop up
to 10,000 songs but let's be honest here
this is really not that important
because they both offer plenty of space
I'll give this one to Apple but it
really does matter so ask for main
benefits Spotify has better
recommendations more social features and
then free service option ask for Apple
they have a better UI stronger music
library and the radio option so unless
you want to have a radio or are looking
for specific music albums that Spotify
does not have and we say that Spotify is
the better service but that doesn't mean
that Apple music is bad it's still
really good and there's one more
advantage that Apple has that Spotify
does not have which is brand power
a lifestyle brand that people have
everything up and as a result map of
music easily integrates with all of the
other products furthermore anything that
Apple sells will sell they can sell a
book for $300 and it will sell wait they
can sell kustra strictly hundred dollars
and it will sell aside from that oppas
destroyed smart competition and passed
several times for example with the
pebble watches Bobby people thought that
pebble watches was the better option
when compared to Apple watches but
despite that and the fact that the Apple
watch is significantly more expensive
Apple watches Kim are on top and pebble
actually closed up again this is because
Apple is a lifestyle brand and people
like having everything from one company
also Apple can form huge brand views for
example buy a new iPhone and get ten
months of free Apple music those types
of things in the case of the Apple watch
it was a good product a significantly
more expensive but with Apple music
Apple music is a good product for a very
competitive price so it's just a matter
of time on apple dominates the music
arena as well now this is a meat that it
is the end of Spotify that's qualify
will always have their three users who
generate revenue and their premium users
who prefer Spotify over apple music but
it does mean that it is the end of their
domination and Apple music will get more
users and more revenue eventually even
if Spotify were to offer a cheaper price
the most realistic price that they can
really offer is $8 a month even if they
were able to go less than that it's only
a couple of dollars in savings per year
with compared to opera $99 per year plan
so Spotify really can't compete in price
so if they wanna have dominate the
market once again you have to come out
with something very unique but unless
something like that happens
Spotify will have to look their
sidelines as alpha music comes in
Spotify was a revolutionary service that
completely changed the way that people
listen to music but recently with the
release of Apple music they have fallen
a bit behind while I would say that
Spotify offers to better overall service
Apple's brand power it's just a matter
of time before Apple music takes over
but I do think that Spotify will always
have its special place but that's what I
have for you guys on Spotify make sure
to comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this video make sure to drop a
like and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one but till then I'm hari
I'll see you guys on next one